- Kelly Clarkson.
- Happy 41st birthday.
- You are very loved.
You're one of the nicest people I know.
Also the funniest people I know.
- I adore you so much
and I celebrate your
existence here on earth.
- My 40s were my absolute favorite.
It's just the best time
in your life and enjoy it.
- I wish you so much love and light.
- Happy birthday.
I am so ecstatic and I congratulate you,
and I respect you deeply
and admire you so much
and adore you.
Mwah! My happy birthday.
- KC. It's KC.
You're gonna be 41, and I
wish I could remember 41.
My only advice to you is
just remember everyday.
- I hope you have a fantastic day.
- We love it.
You're an April baby like me.
You're a cusp.
- We're Aries.
- We're Aries cusp.
- You're Taurus,
but we feel connected.
- You're bringing the energy
and we feel connected.
- Just have an awesome, awesome birthday
and will be thinking about you.
- Happy birthday, Spring Girl.
I hope the sun comes out for you.
I'm sure it will.
Have a beautiful, happy birthday.
- Kelly Clarkson. Happy birthday.
You deserve to celebrate all the things
that you give to others, you sun shiny,
beautiful (beep) soul.
I love you.
- Happy birthday, beautiful.
I know I'm your second favorite person
to tell you happy birthday,
but let me pass on from the Queen herself.
Trisha Yearwood loves you.
She says, have the happiest of birthdays.
- Miss Clarkson, the
happiest of birthdays to you.
- Kelly, happy birthday.
- Happy birthday, Kelly.
- Happy birthday from the past.
- Just know that this year,
from April of this year
to April of next year,
it's all about value.
Where you find value
personally, emotionally,
mentally, spiritually, and professionally.
- [Trio] Happy birthday, Kelly.
- We love you
- We love you.
- Kelly, we've known each
other for so many years.
I feel like our relationship
is so deep and I just,
we've celebrated so many
of your birthdays together.
So here, let's just add another one.
- You're amazing.
So, thank you for the gift
that you've given us by being alive.
Mwah!
- (blows kiss) May you
have many, many, many more.
- Happy birthday, dear Kelly.
Happy birthday to you.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Aww!
That was so nice.